Ladies and gentlemen coming at you live
from Sunny California.
It's bright yellow.
Joe,
how are you brother?
Great man.
How are you?
Long time man.
I haven't seen you in like what?
A year and a half or something.
So something like that.
Yeah,
I see you've got a new place here and
congratulations.
Thank you sir.
Very nice.
Thank you.
It's huge.
It's a big spot.
Got Big plans,
big plans apparently when I have a lot
of fun here.
I think a big old fun house.
Yeah,
that's what they were saying.
You're putting games in and all kinds of
crazy stuff.
The virtual heart treating.
What's the archery game?
Yeah,
you use an actual compound bow,
it's called techno hunt.
And you ever seen those?
Do you play golf?
Yes you do.
You know those games where you whack the
golf ball into the screen and a virtual
golf ball rolls around.
They have one of those for archery.
You actually use a regular compound bow
and you shoot it at the screen.
And when the tips,
instead of using a regular um,
arrow tip,
you use this flat tip.
It's like,
uh,
like the head of attack and here it is
powerful Jamie.
And so you,
you shoot it at the screen and it shows
you like these animals that you'd be
hunting and you use an actual bow and
where it hits it shows you whether or
not it's a good impact.
Like that right there,
it was perfect.
Wow.
And it shows like the Arrow impact,
it shows like how fast the arrows going
to,
you're getting that practice put in here
or do you put it in here too?
I'm very nice.
Not In this room.
Out there in the,
in the whole major.
Yeah.
We're going to do a bunch of shit here.
I'd figure like,
it's like there's so many,
there's so much opportunity now on the
Internet,
uh,
to do things,
to do content.
Uh,
I'm going to do a weekly mma show now
that people know.
I would decided that that's my new
thing,
weekly,
weekly MMA breakdown every week.
How big is,
how big is your resume?
How many things you've got so many.
Well,
I'm not adding the things,
I'm not adding any things,
just doing stuff.
Yeah.
But,
um,
I've told people,
and this is going to sound like I'm you,
you have been successful at so many
different things.
It's very,
it's quite amazing.
I mean,
you have the standup career,
successful standup career.
You were on a Sitcom,
a hit Sitcom,
right?
You did fear factor.
Yeah.
Ratios.
Right?
And then you do the,
what does a wwf,
wwe,
I don't know anything about wrestling
and fighting champion jt that you've got
this podcast.
It's pretty,
pretty,
pretty impressive.
It's not,
I have mental problems and I've figured
out how to boil them down into a healthy
mixture of activities that keeps me
friendly and sane and kind and generous.
We'll get,
it's free.
It's good for you.
Just keep,
it's got to keep moving.
Got to keep moving and keep,
keep my caveman brain engages.
Well,
congratulations on everything.
What's going on with you man?
You still live in Vegas.
You fucking mad,
man.
You're like the nicest guy ever to live
in Vegas.
Everybody in Vegas.
It's like got to Campbell.
I'm fucking going crazy.
I need a Ferrari in la on a bigger
yacht.
Um,
no.
I just,
I,
my kids are in Vegas.
I like living in Vegas,
but I don't really,
I don't really do the Vegas thing the
way other people think.
That's a big misconception,
right?
A lot of people believe that they,
like if you live in Vegas,
like you've gotta be like,
oh no.
The gambler crazy person going to the
clubs.
Yeah.
I have white tigers at home
hanging out with Wayne Newton closet
full of Rhinestone capes.
Ooh.
Yeah.
I'd love to see,
I mean,
I do have that,
but I don't wear them all the time.
You know what I mean?
It'd be awesome if you switched it up.
I'm going to start that.
My next show this weekend,
I promise I'll be wearing rhinestone
capes unstable.
Want to see from you?
I want to see abalone shell glasses like
the outside,
just like a real glistening classes and
then just plumes.
Lots of feathers go on stage and do the
same act.
Yeah,
same.
Amazing.
Once was sprinkles on donuts and go,
is that abalone?
He's wearing an abalone shades.
Yeah.
People would take your pictures and be
able to glistening reflection off of the
off of the frames.
I just feel like you could switch it up.
Yeah.
Maybe one day.
Right now I like doing it the way I do
it,
but it'll be my ace in the hole.
I love what you're doing because you,
you're a guide that has been steadily
performing on a wrecking.
You've built this massive following
where you do these like big giant places
do.
You did red rock in Colorado.
That's fucking huge.
That's a giant place.
I was humbled and honored to be able to
perform there.
It's a beautiful venue obviously.
Have you performed there or seen a shown
that show?
No.
I'm actually in Colorado on Friday and
I'm booking red rock for a year and a
half out in the future.
That's my next gig and Colorado is going
to be red rock.
Oh,
well it's amazing.
I've heard it's awesome.
Yeah.
I,
years ago when I was performing,
come on,
look at the fucking,
the beauty in that place.
I mean you're surrounded by these
natural rock formations.
Goddamn,
I fucking love Colorado.
I love it.
And the,
and the stand on that stage and look up
at the uh,
oh,
that's me.
Oh Wow.
Look at that.
You sign your name on the wall.
Do I never signed it big.
See how small it is,
sweetie.
That's why everyone is excited.
Big.
Look at the fucking,
oh my God.
So that,
that was when I was sick.
That's when I was there.
So you don't have assigned seating,
you just kind of jam it?
I don't know.
I think it's assigned seating.
Oh.
So cause it looks like giant bench
seating.
It
has bench seating.
I was like
fuck.
That's awesome.
And you did it kind of in the daytime?
No,
it started,
it started in the daytime.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
I think that was joe bolster opening for
me.
Um,
who did this video?
Uh,
it was people who did my webpage,
put the video together.
Jamie,
we need to do something like this for
sure.
So by the time it hit the stage,
you can see it was,
it was dark.
Fuck man,
this is amazing.
Holy Shit Dude.
What,
what does the sound like?
We have it dark because there were only
400 people in the entire venue here.
Look at the size of that place.
That's madness.
That's 9,000 people.
That's crazy.
It's so beautiful too,
man.
It's pretty cool.
There's something about that place and
you could run the stairs and get a
workout before you,
uh,
before you actually perform.
I have some friends who live in Colorado
who go to red rock just to run the
stairs.
Yeah,
I walked.
we got there early in the day and I
walked like halfway up just to see what
it was like.
And plus it's a high altitude.
I was like out of breath,
just walking up once halfway.
So there's no way I'm running those
stairs.
Did you ever do Aspen,
aspen comedy festival back when they had
that,
uh,
years ago they used to give you oxygen
backstage.
Yeah,
I've,
I've done shows at high altitude areas
where they will point out where the
oxygen tanks are backstage and say,
if you need it,
they're right.
That's pretty disconcerting.
Weird.
You Go,
why would I need that?
And they go well,
and then they'll mention artists who
needed it.
Do you know who had to come off stage
and take a hit off it or whatever?
Um,
I've never had to do it,
but I have gotten light headed like,
you know,
Breckenridge,
I think I remember being light,
light,
lightheaded on stall.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
I think Aspen,
I want to say it's like a thousand feet
above Denver.
I think Aspen,
it's pretty up there,
which is kind of a crazy place to do a
comedy festival.
Right,
right,
right.
And also when I used to perform at the
comedy works in Denver,
I didn't realize that alcohol would
affect you more intensely at a high
altitude as well.
And I used to drink a couple of beers
before a show and on a three shows
Saturday night,
you know,
and that third show you might have four
or five years in you.
I don't do that anymore,
but I'd be on stayed going lid.
I slurred my punch lines and I'm like,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't like to do that.
I want to kind of be in control.
It's not a good feeling.
Yeah.
You know what's nice though,
right before you lose control,
you got to get like right to the door.
You've got a right to the door is a fun
place.
And on the line right on the edge,
it's hard.
You know we need like,
like a,
like a strip that you could like a lick
getting close here,
you know?
Well I know you like to shoot pool.
We shot pool last time.
It's similar to that when you're,
you have a couple of beers,
like for some people,
and I think I'm one of these,
if I'm completely
sober,
I'm not as good of a pool shooter
because I'm too tense.
Right.
Where if you have a beer or two in you,
you loosen up a little bit where you
play better,
but then you cross the line and then
you're gone.
Yet where it's just,
you're not good at all.
So it's that line you're talking about.
I don't play good under alcohol.
I played good on marijuana,
like marijuana and pool to me goes
great.
But alcoholic just doesn't really,
it doesn't really go that good.
I don't,
I can't even imagine shooting pool
stuff.
Well,
the thing is about marijuana use.
You paranoid,
you get definitely get paranoid.
You gotta think about that for ball is
saying something to me.
What's the deal with the why?
Why are the,
why is the two and the seven together
like that?
I would start thinking weird.
There's a message,
a message in this table clearly.
Yeah,
there's,
there's absolute,
I took a month off,
we did this,
uh,
me and Ari Shaffir and Bert Kreischer
and Thompson Euro.
We did this sober October thing,
ah,
which I'm going to do every year and we
took a month off of everything except
coffee.
And we also did 1590 minute beak from
yoga classes for the month.
Like you owed 15.
So it was a,
it was an interesting little exercise in
discipline because he had to do the yoga
classes,
you had to get a man.
But it was also interesting for a guy
who's been smoking pot pretty regularly
for 2020 years around then for to go to
nothing,
zero.
It was very strange and very
educational.
I think very valuable to kids.
Gives.
Give me,
it gave me a real good perspective on
the benefits of marijuana and maybe
perhaps some of the cons too.
Right?
So this past October,
yeah.
Yeah.
Completely sober.
No alcohol as well.
No,
no alcohol,
no coffee.
Just coffee.
That was the only,
and even coffee,
it's kind of cheating.
I think next time I'm gonna do it with
no coffee.
I think next time because you know what?
Whenever I would see those Aa guys and
they'd be smoking cigarettes and just
pounding coffee,
I'd be like,
hey man,
you're doing drugs,
you know,
something in each hand and they're
going,
I,
I've been,
I've been off the problems for,
uh,
you know,
um,
I think you need advice.
You,
you can't,
you can't.
Maybe there are people who have gone
through this world without having a
vice,
but I think you have to have something,
something that you can go to,
to go,
I know this is wrong,
but as long as you're not hurting
somebody,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I don't know if it's necessarily wrong,
but I agree with you.
I know what you're saying.
I love that term vice.
It's a very interesting term.
Like I remember when you would see like
the old cop movies and they would talk
about like the vice unit,
the vice squad.
Oh,
they'll look at it and then they'd go,
well,
what's your vice?
I'm like,
Shit.
I got to vibe with the vice unit is
like,
there should be a booklet of like all
these vices that are available to
people.
You know?
What is the exact term of vice?
Like Google,
the definition of vice.
Like watch the,
the vice president will pop up here.
Pence people.
You forget who he is when that guy's
gone,
but then I completely forget him.
He's appointed but talking about being
shadowed.
All right,
let's check.
You're looking up the definition of
vice.
He morality,
wrongdoing,
wickedness,
evil.
Inequity.
Hmm.
That's a weird word.
What does that word mean?
Villainy corruption.
Misconduct.
Ms. Deeds more.
There's more.
Click on more was more.
Oh,
cinema's criminal activities involving
prostitution,
pornography,
or drugs.
Now I'm on record saying that everyone
should have one of these.
You need more pornography and drugs and
wickedness and badness in your life.
You need more a moral or wicked personal
characteristics.
That's,
I think those words are too strong that
when I think of advice I think of,
you know,
um,
cigarettes.
Yeah.
Having,
yeah,
I'm going to shut it.
Tequila.
A weakness of character or behavior,
a bad habit.
Cigars happened in V my father's vice.
But how do you put cigars,
right?
And Drugs and criminal activities
together.
Like how do you put criminal activities
and drugs?
How are and,
and cigars,
how are those cigars doesn't fit in
there.
That's um,
well that's a problem,
right?
Like this is the problem with the term
drugs.
Like drugs could be a cup of coffee or
Could be crystal meth.
They're both drugs,
right?
You're going to see a guy smoking a
cigar going,
that guy is wicked.
He's a wicked crypto.
Wicked evil.
I bet cheese into pornography.
But we,
that term vice is a strange term because
we think of it as like a weakness.
And we,
we were very embarrassed of our
weaknesses,
you know?
And if you can get out ahead of him and
then I explain,
oh well,
you know,
coffee's my vice,
I go,
okay,
okay.
You're,
you're giving into your letting us know,
hey you have this,
here's your weakness.
Right.
You know,
but coffee is a pretty yes.
The most innocuous witness that someone
can cop to.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Um,
and it's probably pretty good for you.
I keep reading so hard to tell cause
you're like read one study that says a
cup of coffee a week or a day could keep
you from heart attacks.
Then another one says it takes 10 years
off your life.
It's like it's hard to figure out was
probably the same.
The same line thing.
I like to have a cocktail.
That would be my advice
and a is the wrong word.
Look up.
How many like the idea to have him one
before you go on stage.
I like to have one shot before I go on
stage.
I do a shot of chilled peach schnapps.
Would you give very specific before I go
on stage?
But it's not,
it has nothing to do with the alcohol.
I like the aspect.
So the people I'm working with,
we all do a shot of chilled peach
schnapps.
Oh,
that's nice.
For the ceremony aspect of it.
Um,
that's before the show.
After the show I'll have something maybe
a little stronger than a shot of
children,
which knobs to relax and unwind.
I actually,
I don't,
um,
I don't drink that often,
but I like to have my occasional night
out with the guys where you go,
where you can kind of go ballistic.
It's fun and I,
and I do it safe,
you know what I mean?
I'm not driving,
you know,
uh,
golf weekends with the brothers and
friends.
We're all in a house.
We're getting lit up.
We're not hurting anybody.
I kind of thing I'm with you.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it.
I mean,
what's the,
who it was Oscar Wilde who said,
uh,
all things in moderation,
including moderation.
Love it.
It's a great term.
Great,
great.
A great quote.
Quote Rather.
Yeah,
I think,
um,
I think there's benefits to alcohol.
There's benefits in joy,
like you pay for it in recovery,
but there's benefits in like bonding,
friendship.
Like some of the most fun times I've had
with my friends has been us hammered.
I remember being in college at a party
and everybody being in a living room
cramped like it was shoulder to
shoulder.
Everyone had beers in their hands and
everyone was screaming at the top of
their lungs.
Like everybody,
like it became like an animalistic
tribal.
Like everybody was just
like 60 people jammed together
screaming.
And I remember thinking,
is this just the ultimate and bliss?
It's just a ray,
like an express,
an expression of joy.
You know what I mean?
It was just silly.
It was so unbelievably goofy and silly.
What it's also,
there's the inhibition inducing quality
of alcohol is very important for those
moments.
Right.
Cause he just,
it frees you from any concern about how
you look or how you sound or whether or
not you should be behaving this way and
he could just,
yeah.
Right,
right.
But I wish,
I wish I could do that without the
alcohol.
But you can't like can,
can you get a,
but can I say,
hey,
I need 49 people to come over to my
place.
We're going to have some tea and then
we're all going to get shoulder,
shoulder scream at the top of our lungs.
No one would do that.
No.
You know the,
the alcohol kind of gives you the
freedom and the goofy to be goofy.
Yeah.
And it makes you feel like doing that.
Whereas you,
you wouldn't feel like doing that if you
were sober.
You'd be like,
what the fuck is the benefit and
screaming,
but,
but maybe you do feel like it down deep.
Hmm.
You know what I mean?
I wonder maybe there's something down
deep and then the alcohol brings.
Cause why would you do it when you're
drunk?
That there's something,
there's something that you want,
there's some reason why you're doing it.
Tell you.
One thing that I did find when I was
sober for month is that I would go
out with people who are drinking and
they would be unknown.
Yay.
Oh my God,
it's this fucking,
it's real hard when you're sober and a
bunch of people around you are just
talking stupid drunk shit.
They're on that vibe and you're not even
close.
Nowhere near that by you look,
hey,
look at the time.
Let's get the fuck Outta here.
I gotta get out.
Cause it's funny,
everybody has to be on the same page.
Yes.
Everybody has to be at the same,
the same level of goofiness.
Yeah.
Like if you're dating someone that
doesn't drink and you're a drinker,
that could be a real issue.
You know,
if you start getting hammered and they
were like,
you're annoying.
Like,
no,
you're a fucking sober.
I'm not annoying.
No,
I'm drunk.
This is what happens.
You don't even,
you don't even feel this moment.
Like,
I feel this moment.
Play a good drunk man.
I've been there before.
That's good.
That's strong.
Yeah.
The problem is the physical
repercussions are fucking massive.
Yeah.
Well those are now in my calendar.
Oh,
you got them in Britain in Oh yeah.
Like I,
I know when my crazy night is going to
be and I know that I have nothing to do
the next day.
Oh,
do you a have like pedialyte set aside
and I don't,
I don't know what that is about to know.
He's like an electrolyte drink or
something.
I don't do that.
No.
Maybe IV drip.
I go to bed and set up the IB before I
go to sleep.
Go.
Yeah.
No,
nope.
Just sleep.
Just go to sleep and sleep.
Eat pancakes,
sleep for three days.
That's the other thing too is the food
choices that you get a double whammy
from alcohol.
You get the impact of the alcohol and
then you get the impact of the food
choices that you succumb to.
Waffle house.
Waffle house is good for am fuck yeah.
4:00 AM waffle house.
Talk to me.
Yeah.
When the all American with the,
I get so much food that it can't
literally fit on the table.
They have those little waffle house
tables.
I'll get eggs,
hash browns,
sausage,
the waffles,
you know,
maybe biscuits and gravy.
I don't even fuck with the eggs.
What's why we pretend this is real food.
Just gimme them waffles,
extra butter.
I just,
I don't even start eating until I've
opened like six or seven of those little
packages.
Butter.
I'm going to slather that shit all over
those waffles and then drown them.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But when you got like four guys at a
waffle house table,
it's really,
um,
it's a mathematical problem.
The amount of food that the four guys
are getting truly,
literally will not fit on the table that
they're providing for you.
I've had some fucking amazing
conversations with friends after shows
at the waffle house.
Sure.
Yeah.
But always looking fights
like you always look,
look at it can keep a look out.
Anybody can come in anytime and start
kicking someone's ass.
He was going to be looking to run out
the door.
The Wa there's like something about
waffle houses after 1:00 AM where the
possibility of fights,
it goes through the roof.
The graph just goes up.
You always had to be looking for fights.
Like at any moment one could break out.
So you have like sizzler steakhouse at
6:00 PM to waffle house at 4:00 AM and
the graph just goes through is that
fights at waffle house?
So many of them,
I realized there was actual like web
page dedicated to waffle house videos.
They've seen somebody like,
this guy's got scars all over his face.
See that guy right next to curse Jesus
Christ.
He got beat up at the waffle house.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Waffle house is just something about
that place.
It's 24 hours a day and the alcohol,
right.
The amount of people that are coming in
drunk is through the roof.
I wonder if at some waffle House meeting
somebody propose what we should close at
one 1:00 AM then we're going to cut out
95% of our profits because everybody
comes in after 1:00 AM yeah.
That would be a terrible move this close
at 1:00 AM and see what happens.
That'd be like tiger woods chopping his
fucking arms off.
I've got a stupid idea.
Is that,
that's so dumb.
That's a dumb idea.
Yeah.
They,
they must embrace the drunks,
you know?
Yeah.
Hangover remedies.
You know what else is really good,
really late at night,
if you could find a legit Mexican joint,
like a legit one where they barely speak
English.
You know,
I was at a place in Dallas and there was
a late night place,
a Chinese restaurant where they would
serve alcohol after alcohol was supposed
to be closed.
Oh.
And everybody sold tea.
Yeah.
This is the cool place to go to.
And you go there and everybody's on the
down low and they serve alcohol.
But like in tea cups.
Yeah.
They call it cold tea.
Right.
Something like that.
Yeah.
And um,
the place was packed and everybody had
booze.
And I'm like,
this is really a secret to the,
to the police.
Like the police don't know this place is
packed at three o'clock in the morning
and we're all here to drink tea.
You know what I mean?
And uh,
apparently somebody said the cops are
coming,
like arrayed was happening.
I guess maybe they saw him pulling into
the parking lot and an old Asian guy ran
around all the tables throwing fish on
everybody's table.
And he was saying food saying tell him I
don't want to do an Asian accident cause
it'll sound racist.
But he was saying,
tell,
tell the police you're eating the fish
telling everybody,
tell him you're eating the fish.
Tell him eating a fish.
This big Jane Fish on our plate like
that would fool the cops.
Like everybody has the same giant giant
fish on their plate and a cup of tea.
We just all had a,
I had a craving for this at three
o'clock in the morning.
All of us.
It's a social place.
It's amazing.
They had that many fish cooked ready to
go.
I don't even know if they were cooked.
I think he was just scrambling to try to
cover what was going on.
Chinatown in Boston?
No,
he's had that.
We would do shows at like nick's comedy
stop and then we'd go to a chinatown
which is like right down the street and
they,
they serve cold tea.
You can drink beer late at night.
I think I've been in that place.
I say you have quite a few of those.
Comedians will go,
hey,
we've got a place we can go to.
Yeah,
yeah.
I wish I could remember the name of the
places,
but good Chinese food too.
Like real serious,
legit Chinese food.
And you would,
uh,
you would also get beer late at night.
They must've had some sort of a deal
with the cops because I knew about it
when I was like 18.
So if I knew about it,
I can't imagine that escaped the police
and the entire police force was
oblivious.
Joe Rogan knows about this,
but the entire police force is oblivious
to the fact that this happening in their
town high,
highly unlikely.
It is weird though that there's rules
like,
okay,
that's one of the things that I like
about Vegas is that Vegas allows you to
drink whenever you want.
Your grown adult,
if you want to have a beer at five
o'clock in the morning,
it's totally legal.
If you want to have a beer,
it's seven o'clock in the morning.
That's legal to decide for yourself.
There's no like magical hour where
alcohol becomes okay.
I agree with that.
But I also understand the,
not wanting everybody to get on the road
behind a wheel,
you know,
like,
uh,
aspect.
Yeah.
But does that,
does that really save any money?
Because at the end of the day,
like if you're drunk at midnight,
you're drunk at midnight,
how are you going to get home?
You're going to wait till two in the
morning and then drive.
Is that the idea of,
well,
you're still going to be drunk.
You know,
if you're out there driving and you're
drunk,
you're driving drunk period,
there's no real work around for that.
And if it happens at 11:00 PM or if it
happens at 5:00 AM it's really the same
situation unless you factor where you're
going to be more drunk even later.
And what I mean,
yeah,
I guess so,
but I mean,
how,
what percentage of people that leave
clubs or driving drunk,
it's gotta be in the high seventies and
they just drive,
you know what I like today is like lyft
and Uber that people are using these
ride sharing thing.
That's,
that is gigantic.
And I would imagine that's probably
saved a lot of people accidents.
That would be good to know.
Yes.
And you've had to listen to a lot of
like really stupid stories from drivers
and like had weird conversations with
these people.
They,
um,
I won't,
I have not been in a lot of Uber's,
but they tend to like to talk about
their ratings.
I'll do that because that's what they
survive on is you're going to rate them
so
they,
they want to float the subject that
you're going to be rating them when they
get out.
And they,
I,
I've heard a disproportionate amount of
uber drivers say,
um,
you know,
I usually get good ratings.
I had this one person who I thought I
had done a good job for,
oh,
give me a bad rating.
So I think they're,
they're,
they're pumping you to get out and give
them a whatever,
the highest number of stars you should
get ahead of that.
When you get in the car,
go,
hey man,
here's the deal.
I'll give you five stars.
Just don't talk.
Get me there.
All right,
I thought,
let's go.
He'll play any crazy music,
right?
You're starting at fivestars.
Yeah.
You're,
you're already there.
Just leave me alone.
Let me be in some of my own head.
If you talk about ratings,
that knocks the star off.
Yeah,
yeah.
It becomes a problem when when there's a
forced conversation always,
and if you're paying for that force
conversation,
you're like,
okay,
it's one thing like you want to be
cordial and you want to be friendly.
Like,
hey,
how you doing?
Nice to meet you.
All right,
cool.
But then if they start interviewing you
car service people from years of doing
this there,
there's two kinds there.
The kinds of drivers who they don't want
to talk to anybody,
they they,
that's why they liked this kind of job.
They don't have to talk to anybody.
And then you have the type of driver who
likes a captive audience.
Ooh.
And they will not stop talking.
You know what a real problem has been?
If me and my friends,
I say we get a car service in the road
and we're having like a serious
conversation and then they interrupt and
start chiming in like,
Hey,
well I think the problem is that women
don't understand what men really want.
Oh,
what the fuck is this guy?
Right?
What are you doing?
And if it's like really,
um,
politically weighted or something like
that,
you're going,
you're driving me three miles and I
don't want to get into a political,
it's not tit for tat.
I got an a,
I got an a cab in Las Vegas and I was
going to the Las Vegas Hilton and I get
in the back and I said,
Las Vegas Hilton.
I was already on the strip.
And he said,
uh,
I'm not making this up.
He goes,
oh,
that's not too far.
That won't be too much of a problem for
my anus.
And I said,
excuse me.
He used the word anus.
I'm trying to think of another word.
He used it.
He didn't say ass.
Is there another word between ass and
anus?
Rectum.
Oh,
my wreck.
I think he said it was something like
rectum,
you know,
forcing me into the following question.
Oh,
what's,
what's with your,
with your rectum now you've got an end.
He said that he had had an operation.
He had recently had an operation and
long drives are challenging for them,
but my drive over to the Las Vegas
Hilton isn't too long,
so there won't be too uncomfortable.
And I found it quite odd that I had
known this man for five seconds and we
were talking about that part of his
body.
Yeah.
You got to get
ahead of that.
When a guy like that says something like
that,
you've got to go,
okay,
good.
Well I'll go talk,
grow the amount of space for me to drive
or don't have to worry about my rectum
fallen out.
Okay,
cool.
See,
you're better at these things than I am.
I deal with a lot more dumb people than
you do.
I think.
Well,
from doing fear factor for six years,
I got a phd in questionable humans.
Most of them were wonderful people,
but uh,
every show I had to deal with one
person.
Like what the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
So how did you do?
You did that for awhile and then they
brought it back.
They brought it back for seven episodes
but only six aired because the seventh
one week we had people drink calm.
Ah Huh.
And that killed the show.
Second time I was actually happy I
killed the second time because a,
it was a mistake.
My Shit,
I should have done it,
but it was a bunch of old friends like
the people that were producing it.
We're good friends and it was the
opportunity to work with them and it was
a shitload of money and it was like I
just got talked into it.
It was like,
come on,
it'll be fun.
Like,
Oh,
you talking about the whole experience?
I thought you meant the particular
episode where had no,
now the particular episode,
I couldn't fucking believe it when they
said that's what they were supposed to
do.
I went,
what human or from a mule mule com we
actually discussed this.
That's not so bad.
We actually discussed this yesterday.
Oddly enough with Eliza,
I don't mean to cover,
yeah,
I can't believe it's coming up two days
in a row,
but that happens sometimes,
like subjects come in waves and it's
not,
even if I bring them up for whatever
reason,
they come in waves.
Oh,
I didn't mean to force you into bringing
up that subject again.
Well,
the other problem with the second season
of fear factor,
and I can say this now because it didn't
happen,
is I was worried we're going to kill
somebody.
I was really worried.
It's like it seemed too dangerous.
Like they were ramping up the stunts and
they were making things like way more
spectacular and you're,
you're just taking bigger chances and
there,
there was a lot of downtime in between
starts.
There was a lot of preparation,
there was a lot of like checks and
balances and they,
they really wanted to make sure that
everything was tested and double tested
and they really mapped it out well,
but it was still,
there were some hair raising things he's
fucking people how to do.
Maybe fear was too far.
Maybe it should have been like mildly
uncomfortable factor where you put
people like in mildly uncomfortable
situations like,
Hey,
I want you to go over and talk to that
woman.
She seems kind of attractive,
you know what I mean?
And so it's kind of a mildly
uncomfortable and the no one's going to
die.
No one's going to,
they might,
if she kills you there,
there's um,
they're doing a new one with ludicrous.
It's kind of that way.
There's a new fear factor and ludicrous.
The rapper is the host and like some of
the fears of like forgetting your cell
phone somewhere like for like,
right,
isn't it?
Something stupid like that.
And they don't have to eat anything
gross.
Mm hmm.
Which was a,
it was really dumped and keep that out
because that was one of the most popular
parts of the original series that was
gigantic.
Like the eating gross shit part as huge.
I have to be honest with you.
That was the,
I couldn't watch that.
That was the hard part for I,
I don't,
I hear you.
You know,
it was hard for me to watch somebody do
something cause I wouldn't eat it or
drink it and I don't want to watch
somebody else do that.
But that's,
yeah,
I'm with you.
I mean I wouldn't have won.
Well that's not true.
I watched,
uh,
somebody sent me a clip of Steevo with a
gas mask on and I tweeted it,
some guy farting into a tube and it goes
right in the Steve O's face and he threw
up into the mask and I laughed so hard
that I retweeted it
and yeah,
you send it to me.
It was actually quite rude of him,
but it was in response to Eliza
slessinger his appearance yesterday on
the podcast.
We'll look at this.
Look,
this guy's got a fart into this tube and
the tube goes right in Steve O's face.
Look at this.
He farts and Steve [inaudible].
Oh,
hello.
I liked it.
I almost threw up right there.
I almost threw up.
I'd like to bring like a
revived from the dead,
like Edgar Allen Poe or Mark Twain and
put them in a time machine and bring
them to now and go,
all the stuff you did was make really
cool.
Check out what we're doing now and then
show them that video.
Well they didn't even what the video
back then.
If Eduardo had a cell phone camera,
he might have given up on poetry like
fuck all this Raven's stuff.
Nobody's buying these days.
Blackbird poems.
Does anybody have like a gas mask?
You had a fat guy to party to to let's
make some real entertainment.
Oh Wow.
I mean wonder what I mean that's,
that's a real question,
right?
Like what,
what would people have done?
Like some of the great works,
the people that created like amazing
music where they composed incredible
music or they wrote great books or
poetry.
There wasn't a lot of outlets for your
creativity back then.
I mean,
it wasn't even stand up comedy.
There was no music videos.
There was nothing that you could do.
You know,
that we take for granted today.
It's so commonplace.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you really stop and think about it,
but I mean it's gone too.
I mean,
that's the extreme,
but that's like,
how do you go steve o's a fucking
maniac.
I mean,
I like that.
All different kinds of things that get
explored.
I,
I truly do.
I like that.
You know,
somebody wants to do that,
but people can be entertained by that.
But it's definitely,
that's sort of the end of the line,
isn't it?
Yes.
You know what,
what's,
what,
what could be more outrageous,
steve?
Oh,
we'll find it.
If it's out there further.
Like you,
I was with him in Vegas a couple of
weeks ago.
He came to the UFC and um,
we,
we went to dinner and we were talking
and we're hanging in,
we're hanging out and he's telling me
all these things that he's planning on
doing.
Like I'm,
I light myself on fire and then I'm
going to jump into traffic and then I'm
going to pop port wire around my deck
and now I'm like,
what?
Why,
why are you doing all this man?
And then a guy's going to hit me with a
paddle.
Why those things are written in a
notebook.
Yeah,
well he's just,
he's always got to take it to another
place.
Know he recently had to cancel shows in
Denver because he lit himself on fire
and the,
the burns were so bad that when he went
to the doctor,
you know,
he just wanted to get treated.
He's like,
I'm in pain.
They were like,
Whoa,
whoa dude.
You need fucking skin graphs.
Like immediately.
And so he got to get skin grafts like
all over his arms.
Like,
like look at that.
That's his skin popping and all the
blisters and that's all,
you know,
massive burns.
He lit himself on fire and then did like
fire angels,
like rolled around.
Yeah.
Underground.
And so he had to cancel his gigs.
I think he was at the comedy works in
Denver.
Look at that.
You could see through his skin,
look at all the liquid in his skin when
he moves up to that again,
pulled out again.
That's amazing.
Mm hmm.
Oh,
it's an instagram video.
That's crazy.
Like how you could see the all the pus
roll back and forth and that's quite
fascinating for whatever reason why I'm
interested in that.
So that doesn't interest you.
What?
You're in a sensible guy,
Brian Regan what you get?
Sell some tickets.
I might.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's his thing.
I'm going to be in San Diego and in
between shows I'm going to be a lighting
myself on fire and having like a body
fluids in,
in sacks of pus hanging from my arms.
You're going video tape.
It will sure be hard to just write about
it.
What did he did it until he,
for one fan,
you know it was like a personal
experience like no one else needs to
know.
I'm just going to light myself on fire
and then I'm going to get burns and I'm
going to do like this little puss dance
just for one person.
It's very intimate and personal.
Let me,
let me think about it.
I'm going to,
I'm going to mull it over.
I'm going to mull that one over.
What do you do for fun man?
Besides play golf.
Do you have any weird interests?
Um,
I like watching police chases on
youtube.
Did you,
why?
What bothers me is when they put the end
and the explanation,
oh yeah,
I hate that.
I want,
it's a little drama.
I don't know how it's going to end.
Don't put,
you know,
police chase ends in shooting.
Don't put police chase ends and crash.
Just put police chase and let me find,
do you remember a few years back there
was a,
there was a thing that they did on
television where there was some sort of
a situation where there was a guy who
was a,
he was over a bridge and he had a gun in
his mouth and it was on television.
Do you remember that?
And then he shot himself on TV and they
had apologized because they showed this
guy getting shot on tv and it was like
this really shocking moment for people.
And I was just thinking that that's not
even shocking anymore.
Like the exact same thing today I'd be
like,
yeah,
well now they pull back.
Yeah.
W W when,
when a guy gets out of a car and if it's
unclear whether you know he's giving up
the,
the cameras from the news media will
pull back to prevent people from seeing
something graphic.
You hear him go pull back,
pull back,
pull back because I don't know if
there's a shooting is about to take
place.
I don't know.
I don't like that part of it.
I don't,
I don't like to see that hardcore
violence.
I just like the drama of,
you know,
um,
I'm always intrigued with what these
people are thinking.
Are they thinking they're going to get
away?
You know,
and it's like there's 75 cop cars
chasing you.
There's helicopters overhead.
Do you think you're going to get away
nail?
And it fascinates me.
Has Anybody ever gotten away?
What does this,
some people have though?
I'm in a high speed chase,
bro.
A suspect broadcast on facebook live
this way,
your suit now this is a new thing where
when they're being chased,
they've,
they video themselves.
It's this guy's driving a truck
two and a half hours long this week.
I've seen this two fields and whatnot.
How's he grandma?
I love you.
He says,
how does he have enough gas?
He stopped a few times and unloaded the
ship.
Good move.
The cops tried to get them.
Oh,
that's interesting.
He stopped and,
oh,
he's hanging out of the truck,
but look at,
I watch this guy.
Oh yeah,
that was the end.
He was,
he was going up.
There was about a minute of him driving
in reverse prior to that.
What happened?
They tase him.
Yeah.
And then he ended up in that little pond
or whatever and he's smoking weed.
I love these people,
guy and that girl with their plastic
faces.
The show live pd that's been on on
Fridays and Saturdays?
No,
it's a,
it goes viral.
Viral.
Is that a weird word to use?
But it's trending on twitter every night
because they're technically live with
police like this in five or six,
seven different cities.
Um,
but I think Friday and Saturday nights
and they just follow what's happening.
If someone's getting pulled over for
speeding or drugs or whatever it is.
And they just kind of followed the whole
like cops used to be,
but it's literally live.
Here's the question about like is that
currently this is,
we're living in a time where people
absolutely want attention at any cost.
And does this go back to that because I
love those fucking people.
Those people pause that for a second.
These fucking people,
these broadcast people.
Oh it does it make it blurs it out when
you're,
it doesn't matter.
Those people to broadcast news people
are so odd today cause they're,
they're like a relic of a forgotten time
and I were,
were talking like this was acceptable
and seems like they're dying.
They just nothing left of that.
Like that won't,
that won't exist in 20 years.
It's not,
it's not going to be like that on the
news a because it has already like
evolved away from that with a lot of
radio.
You know how that was like the
stereotypical [inaudible] and then more
and more radio hosts.
We're going,
this is hacky.
We need to just be ourselves.
Well Howard stern but it hasn't done it
yet.
Yes,
exactly.
But it hasn't done it yet with
newscasters.
They still have the low book.
Howard stern singlehandedly killed the
morning joc voice singlehandedly.
Cause I mean it just seems so
preposterous when you would listen to
him be himself and then you would listen
to,
hey,
we're coming up next with some crazy
Brian Regan's in town.
What a funny guy.
Really right back
facts,
you know?
Do you think that these shows though,
like this show that you were talking
about Jamie,
don't you think that they kind of
encourage this kind of behavior?
I mean,
if there's ever an argument that that is
very counterproductive for our society,
like that's,
that's almost like you're,
you're asking people to submit content
for this wacky chase show.
Didn't you say that?
Like it comes on at a specific time,
so how can it actually be,
they know people don't know that chases
are going to take place at a specific
time on a specific day.
Yeah.
Because if you made it live,
if you made it a live show,
we're like,
it's chase Friday.
Who's gonna run?
Who's gonna ride somebody who's going to
do it on purpose.
Yeah.
And by the way,
now they are fucking selling cars that
are so much faster than any cop car.
The corvette just released a new zr one
that has 750 plus horsepower.
They think it's going to do an under
seven minute lap of the nurburgring in
Germany.
I mean this is a fucking insane car that
there's not a god damn cop car in the
world.
It's going to be able to catch that
thing.
You're going to be able to go into a
corvette dealership by one of those
things and you,
you will be so much more powerful than
any cop car on the road,
but it's still not going to outrun a
helicopter.
Right,
exactly.
So,
but it is weird,
right?
Yeah.
By one of those and they keep,
here's the thing,
like you know what Moore's law is when
it comes to computer processing power?
I do not think so.
It's a law of escalation essentially
that you know,
every year computers are going to get
exponentially more powerful and they're
going to keep,
it's kind of like bottom now because
it's really no need for them to get any
more.
Like special,
like personal use.
They've gotten more powerful but not,
not that much more powerful,
but it's going to keep going.
It's gonna keep going.
They're going to get better and better
to force consumerism,
right.
Force people to purchase these things
with cars.
The problem is you're about
acceleration.
Like acceleration is one of the things
that people prize the most like zero to
60 there's cars now that you can buy
right off the lot.
That goes zero to 60 in two seconds.
I get no joy out of that in a car that
that doesn't,
that doesn't thrill me.
Kind of a man of you to be in a car and
see how quickly I could be going fast
and lots of,
I don't mind it being gradual.
I don't mind if it took me
10 minutes to get to six to 60 miles an
hour,
as long as I could eventually get to 60
you say that,
but you want to be able to merge onto
the highway.
Tru,
Tru.
I want to be able to function in my
automobile,
but I don't get a rush out of a,
oh by the way,
I did do the Nascar thing where you
drive the cars.
Have you ever done that?
No,
I did it where?
Um,
at first I was a passenger,
somebody else drove it and then I drove
one that was a rush.
So maybe I do like the zero to 60 thing.
Yeah,
you just haven't done it.
That was on the track in Las Vegas at
the Las Vegas Motor speedway or whatever
it's called.
Most people who think they don't like
fast cars had never really driven a fast
car.
I tell you what,
it was pretty intense.
I was either averaging 135 or top speed,
135.
I forget.
They monitor it.
You do like 10 laps or something like
that.
And uh,
those,
uh,
those stick shifts or is it a pencil?
It's a stick shift and I hadn't driven a
stick and a while.
You know,
it was embarrassing because you,
you do the stick to get out of the pits,
but then once you get on the track,
you're in whatever the the most is your,
it's that the whole time until you go
back into the pits really.
So it's just stick to get in and out of
the pits.
So how many gears is it?
I forget if I forget three four.
And you take a class before and they
show you how to do it.
But when I was coming out to start,
I was just like all dolling it and the
guy had to run up next to me and like
come in and do the stick shift where he
was so embarrassing.
I'm behind the wheel of a Nascar car and
there's a guy running alongside getting
it in the proper gear for me.
What was the last time you drove tick?
30 years ago.
I,
you know,
I had a datsun five 10 years ago and I
don't like it.
I never got used to it.
No,
no.
I,
I never,
you know,
people say,
well you drive it for a while,
then you get used to it.
I never did.
I used to hate that [inaudible] of being
on a hill.
You know what I mean?
And like there's a car too close behind
you and you're like,
ah,
and,
and so you've got to switch it into the
gear and then you know,
you go back like a foot and a half and
then you're just Holland forward.
You just need a break.
You just need a handle,
a break,
and then you hold onto the e brake and
then you slowly,
gently let it go into gear and then let
go the break.
I didn't know that technique.
And he has a problem with like modern
cars that are stick shifts.
They have buttons for [inaudible]
breaks.
And you don't want that.
I was in my,
my,
my brother was driving me one time,
I,
I was 15 and he was making a turn on a
dangerous intersection and the break in
the middle.
Yeah,
the break.
That's okay.
I didn't know what it was.
Oh.
So I,
I did it while he was making the turn.
I said,
what does this do when I pushed the
button and hold it up?
And it's the only time my brother ever
punched me in the arm.
He just goes
sideways.
Cars were coming.
They had to slam on their brakes.
He's like,
why the hell would,
I didn't know what it was.
We'll just pull it up in the middle,
you know,
that's why you're a comedian.
Impulsive buttons.
Push them and find out.
Yeah,
there's a,
so that engineer those into certain
cars,
like if he know Ken Block is
[inaudible],
Ken Block is a very famous driver and
uh,
he has this Mustang called a Hoon again,
is this crazy 1968,
I believe,
Mustang that has four wheel drive and
some fucking insane amount of
horsepower.
And there's these incredible videos of
him driving these things around.
And one of the things that he does is
when he wants to go sideways,
he's shifting gears and he slams the e
brake as he's driving.
Like here,
you can see the,
give us some volume on this,
see that big thing.
He's got two things next to him.
One of them is a shifter and then the
other one is an e brake.
And so as he's driving,
I don't,
I don't know enough about his,
his methods.
I would love to talk to him one day,
65 Mustang.
It's a fucking crazy car man.
I mean it's like straight road warrior.
And is this the Pike's peak one?
Yeah,
I mean this guy's a fucking madman.
I mean a real and a master of the
automobile.
And you watch him as he's driving and
his God damn mesmerizing because he is
on the edge the entire time of this
video.
See that right there.
The one on the right hand side,
that's an outbreak.
So he's in,
he's shifting and then he's going to pop
the e brake and then he's going to shift
forward and,
but watch this motherfucker go see right
here.
If I was sitting next to him,
I would hit the break right now.
Yeah,
go.
What does this do?
Well,
his I'm shifter is a different kind of
shifter.
It's what's called a sequential manual
gearbox,
which means you don't have a,
an h pattern where you go up,
down and to the right until the end,
down to the road.
Instead you're going up for up gear and
down for down gear.
So you just punch it for,
but look at this shit.
He's like on the edge all the time.
See how he keeps hitting the brake and
then going sideways.
And then he's fucking mad,
man.
He's a mad man.
Look at this.
But the control that he has with his
car,
just insane.
It's a,
it's art.
Oh it isn't.
You know,
he's like an artist with his vehicle.
He really is.
I mean,
if,
especially if you're a person like
myself who's an automobile enthusiast
and you get to watch this guy who's just
on the razor's edge of,
of control.
I mean,
look how he's going around.
There's cliffs,
there's rocks everywhere.
The fucking trees and shit.
Guard rails.
He's sideways.
I mean,
and this is,
and is not a long look,
is a two lane road.
It's fucking incredible.
But the manipulation of the two things
of the e brake wear locks up the back
wheels and then look at it.
Look at how he's going in between these
cones.
Are these stacks of whatever the fuck
they are?
That'd be great leg.
If he,
you know,
ask some woman out to dinner and say,
I know a cozy little restaurant at the
top of this hill and then drive driver
like that to the top.
Well you'd get timmy seatbelt on,
honey,
you'd get a girl wants to fuck you
immediately and then you'd get a girl
who wants to have you killed.
He just never wants to talk to you
again.
And she can't wait to go home and write
a blog about what a piece of shit you
are.
See,
when I bring a woman to a restaurant at
the top,
I go,
I don't know if you know,
but this car goes from zero to 60 in
about 10 minutes.
Yeah.
She's going to die in an intersection
like this.
Motherfucker can't,
he can't accelerate.
Look at him driving around cities.
And this is downtown La.
This is London.
Oh,
okay.
He's done in downtown la too.
He goes,
he goes into those,
uh,
under bridges and shit.
So they close off streets for him to do
this.
He's a madman and that car is fucking
beautiful.
It's a crazy car.
Tubes get it because he widen the
stance.
A lot of people hate it because he took
essentially,
which is an amazing classic car from
1965 and they butchered it,
changed it,
put a roll cage in it,
stiffened it up and did all this
different shit to it.
I would try it just so they would
completely empty all the streets of a
major city for me,
just so can to get where I'm going.
What kind of car do you drive?
I just got a new car.
I just yesterday.
Do you know what it is?
Um,
I think it's written on,
don't they write it on the sign system?
It's a 18.
Escolade.
Oh,
those are great.
I rented it.
I rent those all the time,
but I rented one recently.
They're great.
I love those things.
So I just,
uh,
I just got that they're so comfortable.
Yeah,
that's a great God damn car.
The guy was showing me all the,
all the stuff and I felt like going,
just stop,
stop.
I don't,
I don't literally back massage in the,
I'm like,
I just need the gas and the brake and
the radio.
You know what else does too and it's
like kind of it.
If you're about to change lanes and you
fuck if like someone's too close,
it'll give you like give you like a
vibration.
I'll let you know that like there's
something on that side.
He said that if you don't have your
blinker on,
I haven't tried this yet.
If you don't have your blinker on and
you to cross the line,
it will automatically pull you back.
Whereas if you have your blinker on,
then the car knows.
I don't know if he was just bs thing or
what,
but that's what he told to make a quick
maneuver.
That's what I said.
So what if?
What if you're trying to,
yeah,
to get over.
You know the card is going to take over
that.
I think that's quite strange.
Yeah.
I'm torn because on one hand I love
gadgets.
I love technology and I'm fascinated by
that.
But another hand,
like the connection that you have to the
actual mechanical feeling of the
automobile is,
is very muted.
Also,
have you heard about,
you know,
the technology is getting closer to
closer to self driving cars and,
but now there's the moral component and
they're like,
if you're not in charge of the car and
the car is about to have an accident,
the human being has the decision to make
a moral choice.
If there's,
uh,
a woman with a baby stroller on the
right and there's a cliff on the left
and you have your family in the back,
are you making a left or a right?
The human can make a conscious decision.
A computerized car can't make a decision
and they actually are trying to figure
out how to have the cars make moral
decisions and keeping with your own
moral decisions.
You can,
you can gauge it and go,
I'm more for my family or I'm more for a
more altruistic yeah,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Yeah.
So what like what would a car do?
Like if it's like,
well there's a,
uh,
a family,
there's an older guy over here and
there's a young woman with a child over
here and you have to hit one.
Jesus.
How does a computer make that decision?
Yeah,
it doesn't.
Or the decision to,
yeah,
the cliff thing.
It's a good one.
Like does it run into the child and the
woman or does it go off the cliff and
kill everyone in the car?
Exactly.
Or if your bike,
and it would be different if you're by
yourself or if you have your family.
Like I will say my family,
but maybe I would go myself if it were a
baby,
you know what I mean?
Like,
but a human can make that decision in a
split second,
but a computer,
what's it supposed to do?
Well,
one of the things that's gotten much
better that I think is amazing,
it's breaking like your car can brake so
much faster now.
They have a amazing breaks now in cars.
And though as as technology gets better
and better in that regard,
you're going to be able to prevent a lot
of collisions.
The other thing is that with car to car
collisions,
there's some talk about developing
technology that literally has cars repel
from each other.
It's sorta like how magnets do and that
if they could figure out a way to make
that efficient and effective enough,
they can virtually eliminate car
accidents with those two things,
with automated vehicles.
Um,
and then with the,
the kind of technology that would force
cars to repel from each other.
A bunch of repelling magnets.
Yeah.
I mean,
just put repelling magnets on every car.
So they're just the camp.
They can't get any closer than five
feet from each other.
Then the real question is like,
what if you get close to a deal with a
pacemaker and you just fucking ice and
taking a right turn?
This guy just drops right there.
So all the cars are safe.
But this guy,
he's given a massive heart attack.
That's the thing with pacemakers,
right?
Magnets.
I think so.
I think magnesium really fuck up
pacemakers.
Hmm.
Did you see that Christian Bale is going
to play Dick Cheney?
Speaking of Pacemakers,
um,
you know Dick Cheney at one point in
time literally is the antichrist.
He had no pulse.
He had some kind of crazy heart valve
thing where,
uh,
he had some artificial heart in his body
that literally was pumping the blood
constantly with no heartbeat.
So he had no heartbeat.
That's strange.
It's terrifying when you think of what
an evil,
fuck that Guy Christian Bale looks
almost unrecognizable after putting on
weight and shaving head for Dick Cheney
role.
You know what he looks like?
He looks like the guy who designs
iphones.
You know that God,
the Chris didn't demand who talks like
this.
The amazing oled led screen.
Yeah,
right.
Am I wrong?
Did you see what he lama said that he's
a,
they're making a big announcement this
week about what?
The semi truck.
Oh,
the going to have an automated truck
blow your mind or pull your head clear
out of your skull.
Interesting.
Into an alternate dimension.
Just need to find my portal gun.
He's a weird cat,
isn't he?
He's got a lot of shit going on.
You talk about guys do a lot of things
that Elon musk character,
we're thinking a lot of goddamn irons in
the fire.
Isn't he trying to,
uh,
do a manned mission to Mars?
Is there,
yeah,
he wants to do that.
Yeah.
Would you go fuck that?
No.
Here's the thing.
Space space is infinite.
Space is infinite.
We are literally in the best
neighborhood in space.
That's the way I look at it.
When I'm looking at like getting,
getting to Mars is just like you're,
you're going to a shitty neighborhood
that you can't return from.
Well,
hopefully you can return from it,
but you can answer.
The plan is to go there and come back.
They're not,
they're not bringing people there to
die.
There they are.
They're bringing people there to
colonize them.
Their initial people that go to Mars
until they figure out how to some way on
Mars to return to earth.
The people that go to Mars the first
time or just going to stay there.
I did not know that.
I thought this was get there,
get on his craft and come.
I do not believe so.
As of two years ago when I had a bit
about it,
it was all about them going there and
dying there,
Huh?
You're going to die on Mars and you can
die on Mars with a bunch of other people
that are so fucking stupid.
They're willing to die on Mars with you.
You're still in space.
See,
this is the thing,
we are in space right now.
We are just in an amazing vehicle for
space travel.
We're on earth and we're here at
southern Sun,
sunny southern California where the
weather's beautiful and you've got a
nice starbucks here.
We're sitting here in this beautiful air
condition studio,
but we're in space.
Okay.
What'd you send the best spot in space
to go to?
Mars is just fucking dumb.
It's a dumb idea.
No,
no.
We're,
we're we explorers and we will always
want to know what's on the other side of
the mountain.
You know what I think it's like there's
no stopping us.
I think it's like one of those guys that
creates the very first wingsuit and
jumps off a cliff and then breaks both
of his legs versus you taking a flight
to New Zealand.
She had to take a fun,
nice flight team.
You could have a lovely dinner,
catch a nap,
watch a movie,
land perfectly.
If flight attendants are all great,
you're a fucking explorer.
Okay.
That guy's an asshole with broken legs,
right?
Right,
right.
That guy that did that,
this the guy that did the wingsuit off
of Mount Everest,
speaking of Youtube clips,
he passed away jumping off some other
mountain.
That's a wonderful way to put it.
Then he passed away,
passed away.
He died.
He down.
I don't know how long ago adventure
athlete dies.
Attempting 22,000 foot wing suit jump.
You know what's uncomfortable about this
to me is one of my very good friends is
andy stump and Andy is a world record
holder in the wing suit jump.
He's a fucking a bonafide maniac navy
seal.
Complete total psychopath who lives for
thrills.
The only thing that's saving andy is
that he's gotten into bow hunting.
He's now bowhunting constantly and that
is his new thrill ride.
He should,
he should put on a wing suit,
jump off a mountain with the bow.
He need to be just on,
I have to go over and fire fire at elk
as you're,
as you're zipping down.
It's totally unethical sir.
These,
your told that this is a terrible
advice.
This is Andy had the world record for
the longest ever wing wing suit jump.
Is that him flying over the American
flag on his twitter?
He's a maniac.
Like a legit,
I just people that claim by,
I'm a maniac man.
Now this guy's a fucking legit maniac.
So that's obviously a of a plane.
Can't get that high.
No,
he gets on a plane with an oxygen mask
and shit.
He gets so high that he's,
you know,
he's in the place where there's no air
like he would black out if you just
tried to breathe the air.
What's the craziest thing that you've
done?
Um,
scary wise.
You know where you were risking your,
there's him right there.
It's crazy.
Fuck.
He's got a podcast too by the way,
folks is very good.
Podcast.
It's called cleared hot with Andy Stump.
He's a very,
very interesting,
intelligent,
articulate guy.
So he needs the oxygen cause he's so
hot,
he's,
I mean he's not just a maniac,
he's a very,
he's a brilliant guy,
but he's a fucking maniac too.
Um,
I haven't done anything like that man.
I mean back in my,
I guess when I was competing,
kickboxing and taekwondo tournaments
were probably the scariest thing is
being in a fight.
Like yeah,
fights are scary,
you know,
especially the potential to get knocked
unconscious.
You just see a lot of,
I mean I've,
I've seen a lot of people get knocked
unconscious and all my days I probably,
I probably seen more people get knocked
unconscious then 99.9% of all the people
that have ever lived.
I think that's a,
that's an honest statement.
Cause think about all the fights that
I've called.
I've called more than a thousand UFC
fights easily more than,
I don't know how many hundreds of events
with 10 plus fights on each event.
And then on top of that,
I've been to so many tournament's
taekwondo tournaments,
kickboxing events,
just like just seeing people get
smashed.
Like,
but that's,
I've,
I've taken people to fights for the
first time and there's a thing that that
happens when they see like a live fight
for the first time with it.
Just like he see the look on their face.
Like they walk out,
they,
they're like Jesus Christ.
Like,
like a,
a good buddy of mine,
Steve Rinella who's a,
he's a hunter is you got a television
show called meter and he's a
conservationist and outdoorsmen and he's
seen a lot of animals die but him going
to see live fights.
They got this,
they have this look on their face like
holy shit.
Like once,
once you see it in your,
their clothes and see the impact and you
see guys get knocked unconscious and you
see that it,
what happens when someone gets kicked in
the head like right in front of you,
you're like,
Holy Shit,
I went to one.
Yeah,
you guys were kind enough to invite a
went out with the Hannibal burress.
Yeah,
that was great.
And,
uh,
yeah,
it was fine.
That was the first time I'd ever seen
anything like that.
Hannibal loves it.
Yeah.
And it was like pretty intense.
It was it weird for you?
I thought
he texted me and said,
do you want to go to the fight tonight?
I thought it was,
there was a boxing match cause I live in
Vegas and I thought maybe there's a
boxing match.
So I'm Google boxing matches in Las
Vegas and nothing came up.
I didn't know what he was talking about.
He goes,
meet me.
What does it,
the MGM,
yeah,
it was probably the mgm,
because meet me at the,
we'll call it mgm.
We'll get our tickets.
So I go meet him and he picks up the
tickets.
He goes,
let's go.
I thought we were going into a boxing
match.
We go in the door.
That's the first time I saw the octagon
ring or whatever that is a cage.
And I'm like,
oh,
it's this.
I didn't even know until I went in
there.
And then,
uh,
you know,
we had good seats close enough.
And so that was the first time watching
it.
It was you guys had,
you guys got my seats.
You guys were super close.
Yeah,
it was fantastic.
You could see it in a way that it's,
there's something about being really
close.
It's like,
that's the way to see it.
Like when you saw it live
for your very first [inaudible],
if you ever watched it on television a
little bit here and there.
I'm not a big,
you know,
fighting guy.
So yeah,
but,
but live is always better in every,
every entertainment.
Usually it is,
but there's something great about,
well,
watching things on television too,
because you watch things on television,
you get the replays and you get the
commentary that explains true.
Like if things are going wrong or what's
happening,
um,
sometimes you're in the dark.
If you're in the audience,
you're like,
why?
Why are they stop in this?
What's going on?
Like you don't really know what's going
on.
But,
uh,
and then like the other thing about
watching it live as you're looking
through the cage,
so oftentimes you catch yourself looking
up at the big screen anyway,
but you're still there right now.
There's a feeling that you get in that,
you know,
especially now they do it with a t
mobile arena,
which is 20 plus thousand people and
it's just fucking rocking and it's
intense.
I was impressed with,
I mean there's the,
the violence aspect of it,
but I was impressed with the chess match
aspect of it.
There's,
there's two people and it's a mind thing
as much as it is a physical thing.
Oh,
100%.
So watching them look at each other and
figuring it,
it's a chess match,
if you will,
for back.
Lack of a better analogy.
You don't anyway,
so that's part of it as well.
I describe it as high level problem
solving with dire physical consequences
cause that's really what it is.
Yeah.
I mean you have us,
you have this series of techniques that
you're allowed to execute and then
you're trying to do them on a skilled
fighter.
And then if you mess up,
if you,
if you don't have the discipline to get
into the cardiovascular shape that's
necessary.
If you're not at a camp that has the,
um,
sufficient technical knowledge and then
pays enough attention to you and someone
who really understands how to train
fighters.
Like there's so many variables and it's
very hard for someone to find the right,
like the perfect mix of those variables.
Right.
You know,
and,
and then on top of that,
you have to have enthusiasm.
Like enthusiasm comes and goes and you
see it,
you see it leave fighters like there's
fighters are you see like,
oh,
this,
this guy should stop.
It's gotta stop.
I don't think you could do that if you
didn't have enthusiasm.
You imagine go,
no.
See that's where you're wrong.
Yeah,
no,
that's,
it's comms guys coming at me again,
I just don't feel up.
I just don't feel up to defending
myself.
That's not what I mean.
What I mean is like,
there's levels of excitement when it
comes to the exchanges and you either
are going into it,
there's like,
this is weird.
You should either do it because it's a
fun hobby and you're just trying to
experience a very difficult thing and
try it out.
Or you should do it because you want to
be the best in the world.
Those are the only two things.
If you're just a guy who is going to
take some fights,
I'm not telling you what to do,
do whatever you want,
but in my experience,
those are the guys that get hurt.
Like I feel like you should,
you should own because you'll run into
someone who's trying to be the best in
the world and the intensity that someone
has that wants to be the best of the
world,
and somebody who really might has the
potential to actually reach that goal.
Those people are fucking scary and
[inaudible].
There's a difference between them in you
that it might not just be physical,
it's enthusiastic,
it's,
it's enthusiasm and its focus.
What if your goal is to be number 500
you're fucked because you're gonna run a
[inaudible] 99 four 99 is going to kick
you in the face.
Well,
just make sure you have a good manager.
I don't want to fight anybody that's for
99 or higher.
Oh,
okay.
You know what I mean?
You could probably pull it off,
but even then the attitude that would
say,
I don't want to fight anybody for 99 or
higher you,
you would like run into someone that
even though they're ranked five 12
there's still more enthusiastic they
want,
they want to get to four 99 enthusiasm
is a big part of it and there's an
intangible quality like you could see it
happen in fighters.
And for me,
when I watch it happen,
it's very disconcerting because I
remember it actually happening to
myself.
So I recognize it and I see it happen in
these guys and I'm like,
oh,
this guy doesn't want to do this
anymore.
He's got to stop.
Like you got to get out of this because
you're just going through the motions
and you're hoping it comes out well and
it's not going to like you have to,
it has gotta be,
it's gotta be more powerful,
a more powerful force driving you.
It has to be a singular pursuit.
I don't,
I really don't believe that you can be
an elite professional fighter while
doing anything else.
You can't moonlight.
Yeah,
exactly.
As a fighter.
It's just too fucking hard.
I mean,
you can have a day,
some sort of a day job,
like the heavyweight champion.
The world is actually a firefighter,
steep emile chick.
He's actually a legit firefighter,
which I,
it makes me uncomfortable.
I would,
I would like him to make enough money
that he doesn't have to be a firefighter
or do anything else on the side,
but he hasn't had like the big fights
yet.
I'm sure he's made good money,
but he hasn't had like the big,
big fights here.
Are there any accountants who,
I'm sure there's some that try it,
get into it.
That's uh,
that's pretty,
I mean,
obviously you,
you love it,
you know,
it,
it's,
it's something that I don't know that
much about,
but I enjoyed watching it on that
evening.
It's intense.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen a bull fighting live?
No,
I don't.
I don't agree with bull fighting,
but I think I would like to see it live
just because I think it's like it's
going to happen whether I'm there or
not.
And I think there'd be,
it's like,
I feel like that's one of those things
that's a leftover cruelty from a,
from a past era.
Like I don't think if someone tried to
introduce bull fighting today in North
America,
there's no fucking way.
No,
of course not.
Right.
But it's still exists.
You can go watch it right now if you go,
I guess to Spain or some other
countries,
I,
yeah,
it bothers me that it doesn't seem fair.
The fight isn't fair.
It's not fair.
You know what I mean?
100% but every now and then the underdog
wins,
right.
Every now and then that guy gets a horn
right through the rectum area
and then they've got to drive to the Las
Vegas Hilton.
There's some horrible,
you want to talk about videos you could
watch online.
There were some horrible videos of
bullfighting gone wrong.
It happens quite often,
often enough that there's,
you could spend hours watching bull
fighters get fucked up.
Yeah.
Eh,
not,
not for me.
There's a new type of bullfighting they
do,
they call ethical bullfighting where
they don't actually fight the bowl,
but they jump over the bowl as a bull
comes at them.
This is a joke.
No,
I'm,
no,
it's not a joke.
There's a bunch of guys who were like
acrobats and they stand in front of the
bowl and as the bull comes at them,
they leap through the end and they flip
over the bowl.
Wow.
And sometimes that goes wrong to,
somebody sent me a video,
said you called it and uh,
I watched the video and it's like,
dude,
trying to flip over the bull and the
bull catches him on the way up and
fucking crushes him.
Have you seen on cspan the,
the bull debates with a,
they have two podiums and there's the,
the one person and then the bull is at
the other podium and they debate like a
controversial issue.
But yeah.
Why would they do that?
The bull debates that the humans are
always win because they have the human
brain.
The Bulls are just standing there.
What is the bull representing?
You know,
they'll like say global warming and then
the,
the guy will give his opinion and then
they go and how about,
how about you bull and it just,
it just stands here.
What the fuck are you talking to?
Haven't won one debate yet.
I serious.
No,
I'm sorry.
I'm so confused as to where you're going
with this.
I was like,
what?
I'm looking at you while I'm doing this,
going this.
I thought this was so clearly absurd.
It was absurd.
And your weight on cspan.
Where's this and this day and age,
it's not,
it's not absurd enough for me to
absolutely assume the joking around
Jamie.
Get a video of that.
Those uh,
acrobatic with the little debates.
I can't find it.
I was looking at ethical bullfighting
bullfighting with no hands and it's not
coming.
I remember we just looked it up.
How we see a bull fighting with
acrobats.
I know it was going try that.
There we go.
Acrobat.
Yeah.
Acrobats.
It's kind of bad ass cause these guys
are there.
It's super impressive what they can do
with their bodies anyway.
But then you see like a bull coming at
them.
Check this out.
Fuck that thing is a big animal.
Yeah,
there are no nothing.
He's just moved.
Just trying to avoid it.
Yeah,
but this is a guy just moving.
But wait til he flips.
There you go.
Oh,
okay.
Let me get that.
I mean that it's fucking incredible.
Conan,
we watched,
they had picked their hands in their
pockets even.
Yeah.
I mean that guy bounces and does a giant
front.
That's a bad motherfucker.
But this is Kinda cool because look,
it's still fucked up because you have
this wild animal or you know,
captive animal rather,
but at least he gets to live.
Yeah.
It gets to live and then people get to
watch this craziness.
I've seen this with cars.
Oh yeah.
I saw a guy get hit.
People jumping over cars.
Like somebody sent me an Instagram,
one of a guy doing that and he got hit
by a car.
Oh my God,
this guy's on his knees.
Oh,
he's a crazy asshole.
Are they going to show some bad examples
of this?
We can see a few bad examples.
If you really want to look at you,
you're a cruelty person.
Acrobatic bullfighting goes wrong.
I'm trying to dissuade someone out there
who's watching this go,
maybe I should do this for a living
show.
The downside,
yeah,
there's definitely downsides.
I a video the other day of this car gets
smashed.
Is this guy going to get smashed?
No idea.
I was just looking,
I guess it doesn't seem like,
oh my God,
this is like a whole team of these
deals.
Look at this.
This is a new thing,
but I mean I just found out about this a
couple of months ago and there's fucking
a ton of videos and a bunch of events,
so this is a old papers.
Boy.
This is an incredible how athletic these
guys that says even a six year old
video.
What?
That's amazing.
Bull leaping dates back to antiquity.
It says 18 century.
Oh my God.
That guy's amazing.
To antiquity that.
That's old.
Yup.
For sure.
That guy is fucking amazing.
It's just amazing how good he is.
A dodging and the concept.
Oh,
he got close.
He gets the consequences are awful.
That bolt once.
I'll fuck you up.
Whoa.
I was a chick.
She's going to get in there too.
Please don't kill the girl.
Yeah.
Shit.
Jesus.
Honey.
Get out of there.
Whoo.
Look at her.
Go.
Damn.
That's like they showed of her.
Turned their back too.
They turn to the back hole one.
It's the same club.
Yeah,
it was the same clip gals out of her
fucking mind.
They're all out of their fucking mind.
Hurry,
get to wear some cool outfits.
Animals.
Got To be careful.
Danimals Brian Regan,
do you have pets?
No.
I was thinking of getting a fish,
but decided against,
you know,
that tanked company that had the,
the,
the TV show.
Well,
they're based in Las Vegas.
I don't think the show is on anymore.
So I had them come out and they're have
a wall where I wanted to have some,
uh,
fish and we did the whole thing.
We did the structural stuff.
I can't,
you have to feed fish every day.
Uh,
I'm not there every day.
And I said,
well,
the only way I can do this is if I have
an electronic feeder or whatever,
and they said we can do this and it just
ended up being way too much of a a thing
so I'm not going to do it.
The real issue with them is you gotta
clean the tank too.
I would not do any of that.
I would have people come by and then the
people or by your house all the time.
Exactly,
man.
They have to come once a week and it's
like it's too much of a commitment.
It is a lot to have fish that I don't
have any,
you know what am I going to look at it
and just go to the aquarium?
Well since you were in Vegas,
go to Mandalay Bay and that's shark.
Yes.
Been there.
That sounds awesome.
Pretty cool.
Have you ever been at Jamie in the
Mandalay bay?
I didn't.
I actually didn't even see the shark
thing when I was there last time.
It's fucking great because they have
this huge gigantic tank with the sharks
swimming around in it.
It's been a while since I've been there.
But I think you can go underneath them
like they can swim above you and I might
have that wrong.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if that's the case.
You can do that.
Some places I've definitely been Kansas.
Jim Shark Reef.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
That's inquired is,
yeah.
I mean the amount of effort,
we did a fear factor in Mandalay bay and
so they,
they gave us this tour of how this all
works and uh,
the amount of resources that are
involved in running this fucking thing.
It's crazy.
Do you fish?
Do you ever go fishing?
Uh,
years ago one with a bunch of buddies,
we chartered a boat out of Miami and
went out and um,
we were catching nothing and then all of
a sudden we hit this school and everyone
was going Berserk.
I mean,
pulling them in every 30 seconds to a
minute,
50,
60 fish flopping around.
It was,
it was amazing to go from nothing.
Maybe it's similar to to hunting where
you just sit there for most of the time
and then all of a sudden there's an elk
or something.
Sometimes it was like nothing.
And then all of a sudden everybody's
just on fire.
It was pretty intense.
I had that happen once in Mexico.
We went to this,
uh,
we,
we went on a charter boat and they'll
take you to where I think they were.
Amber Jack I think.
I think that's what it was.
But anyway,
there's this literally like a football
size,
football field sized school of these
fish fucking up these bait fish and the
water just frothy,
just crazy without it.
Like it was amazing and just cast into
that giant football sized field and they
would just smash the lure.
Like instantly you just pulling fish as
much as quick as you can.
So as long as this feeding frenzy went
on,
you could pull fishing.
And so then we brought those fish back
to the hotel that we were staying at and
we bring it to the restaurant and they,
they have like this whole thing that
they do.
You talked to the chef and the chef
says,
how would you like you prepared w we can
make some severe,
we can bake some fish,
we can cook it in a variety of different
preparations for you.
And so they did that.
And so you're eating fish that's like
three hours old,
four hours old.
So we had it for lunch.
It was incredible.
So good co there's a comedian,
Jim Collin could friend of mine,
he said he was out with buddies of his,
I don't know if it's part of his act and
if I'm giving him complete credit,
but all of his buddies were on a charter
charter boat and they all caught fish
except for one guy.
So one of the guys that worked at one of
the attendance or whatever set,
I'll take care of this and went to the
other side of the boat with a snorkel
and jumped on the opposite side of the
boat and swim and grabbed the dead fish
that had already been caught when
underneath hooked the dead fish to this
guy's line and started shaking it like
underneath the boat.
Oh Geez.
To make it look like it was catchy.
And the guy like I got one,
I got one and they pulled it up and um,
they just grabbed it really quickly.
It just through it.
So he couldn't see that it had already
been caught and dead.
And to this day,
that guy thought that he caught a fish.
What?
Yeah.
And Really?
Yeah,
they faked it on him.
Wow.
That's elaborate.
It must be something that they,
for the guide already know this
technique.
Maybe they do this.
Maybe that's a thing where they make you
pretend like you're catching fish.
How drunk was he?
A while.
I would factor in,
I'm sure a bunch of guys on a boat
fishing.
Of course they're drunk.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Boat fishing drunk is okay.
Hunting drunk.
Not Okay.
Two very different pursuits,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
But even fishing drunk yet to be
careful.
You get hooked in the ass with a hook
and the face catch you in the head.
I've people get their ears
hooked.
Yeah.
Someone's gonna cast and the,
the hook just catches you as you.
Hi,
Whoa,
ouch.
Listen,
we don't have to talk about terrible
things.
Just talk about good things.
So you're in,
uh,
San Diego this weekend and Stockton,
two Oh nine,
right.
San Diego.
Friday two shows Saturday at the terrace
theater in Long Beach.
Oh,
that's a good spot to,
yeah.
And then Sunday in Stockton,
California.
How many weeks a year detour?
I try to do half the weekends of the
year,
so 26 weekends a year and I will do four
of those nights.
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday and Sunday.
Oh Wow.
So it's about a hundred shows.
Damn.
You hit it hard.
I love it.
I mean,
this is what I,
what I do,
you know what I mean?
And how do you write,
do you write
and um,
perform in local spots in Vegas?
No,
I do it in my shows.
You know what I mean?
I just come up with something and try to
book,
end it and squeeze it in there.
So he squeezed it in there between
already established bits and then you
let it grow.
Sordo yeah.
And,
um,
you know,
I don't know what my batting averages
maybe average,
you know,
in terms of new bits,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean,
some stuff just gets nothing.
It's always going to happen.
Yeah.
There's the batting,
that's something that people that don't,
they've never tried comedy really
probably don't understand,
is that most of our stuff.
It's one of the reasons why plagiarism
is so awful.
It's because by the time a bit become
something that actually works,
the amount of effort that goes into it
to get it to work like your,
your Steve,
you're not just stealing this idea.
You're stealing this gigantic process
that created this idea.
Yeah.
It's definitely frowned upon in any
field,
but us being comedians,
it's,
it's particularly a egregious,
well,
it's also agregious because there's no
recourse unlike,
um,
as sort of as now,
you know,
you can make youtube videos and get
people angry at the person.
Right?
But you in the,
like if you have music or literature or
anything,
a movies,
it's very clear.
Like when someone plagiarizes and people
get fucked music,
it's a giant issue.
Obviously.
There's been massive,
massive lawsuits from people just
stealing rifts,
right.
With completely different lyrics.
And you know,
they've sued for the entire value of a
song just for using samples and using
pieces of it.
I mean,
there's a lot of songs that were
gigantic hit songs that the people who
wrote the songs want to making no money
because they were,
it was deemed that they had stolen
chunks or parts of that song from
somebody else.
I liked the fact that they can go after
somebody legally,
but what if you're wrong?
You don't like the Beatles.
The Beatles are one of the,
one of the Beatles lost a court case
about having stolen a song.
Oh yeah.
And I don't remember what the song was,
but you know,
and you can play two songs to each other
and a jury or whoever's deciding can
just say,
well yeah,
that's so close.
It was obviously taken when maybe it
wasn't right.
Yeah.
Maybe two people thought of the same
thing.
Definitely happens in comedy as well.
Yes,
definitely.
For sure.
I've had,
um,
I had a situation,
you remember Dennis Wolfsburg?
Sure.
Dennis Wolfsburg used to have a bit
years ago.
Dennis Wolfsburg,
wonderful comedian.
He's no,
he's no longer with us.
Um,
and he had a thing about how the terms
imbecile idiot moron are actual
technical,
scientific,
um,
levels of intelligence and a,
there hired,
there's a hierarchy to them.
And so you could call somebody an
imbecile and it's a compliment because,
you know,
there's,
there's a,
a dumber level or whatever,
right?
So he used to do this whole bit about
it.
And then I went out and I started at the
Comic Strip in Fort Lauderdale,
and then I went out on the road and I,
I thought I had thought of it,
you know what I mean?
Like,
so I was doing a similar bit,
and I'm not for not that long.
And I had a comedian come up to me,
and I'm glad that our comedy community
is so tight that this other guy sensed,
he said,
I just want you to know Dennis Wolfsburg
has a very similar bit.
He goes,
I don't know if you know that or not.
And I said,
you know what?
I now remember him doing the bit,
uh,
I now remember it and I think that I,
I thought I thought of it,
but probably the original inspiration
was seeing him do it.
Yeah.
And I,
I dropped,
I dropped it like a dime.
Like I was like,
that's it.
I'm never doing it again.
You know what I mean?
So there,
there are instances where you can,
I'm sure there are outright themes,
we all know about that,
but you can also mistakenly come up with
something that you think you thought of.
So it,
it's,
you have to really guard against guard
against that.
It's a really,
yeah.
Tricky thing.
Yeah.
Well,
that's very honest of you,
but that's,
I think that is the case with a lot of
things.
I think we're,
we're very often inspired by other
people's work,
whether we recognize it,
we recognize it or not.
That's the George Harrison,
George Harrison versus fonts.
Yeah.
Um,
I think,
uh,
I mean everybody's influenced in some
way,
shape or form by other people's work.
There's just no getting around it.
It's just a matter of whether or not
that you made a conscious decision to
copy someone versus whether or not you,
you have been somehow or another
influenced,
and in your case,
it's just a,
a forgetting thing.
I mean,
that's,
that that also happens.
You could just make a mistake,
you can just forget.
Right.
But I think the,
uh,
then,
then you have to make the decision where
you go,
all right,
now that it's been brought to my
attention,
what am I going to do about this?
So I'd like to think I made the right
decision once it was brought to mind,
to my attention.
Yeah.
Well did you definitely did.
You definitely made the right decision.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
do you write like on a computer,
like how do you
just Nah,
I think of something,
I don't know.
I don't know how that happens is I don't
know how people think of things.
I don't know how I think of things.
And then once I have it,
then I apply a little bit of a,
all right,
how am I going to put this to have a
beginning,
middle and an end?
Say it out loud a few times to try it on
stage tape and then listen and then
sometimes,
okay.
I always feel sometimes some of the best
writing takes place on stage.
Like I think you can have something to
qt and clever like if you write it out,
but when you're on stage there's a piece
of you that goes,
take this and say this a hundred percent
a hundred percent I completely agree.
This is way too wordy and when when
you're on a legal pad or a computer,
you throw a lot of adjectives and you
get,
I think you can get to conceptual where
it's like when you're on stage,
something takes over and says tighten
this right now.
Yeah,
and you get right to the quick.
isn't it?
It's weird art form.
Like I was,
I was talking to a friend of mine who's
a musician about this and I was saying
the difference is like you can come up
with an amazing album in the studio and
you can tweak it and go over things,
but we kind of have to do it in front of
people,
right?
Like to create like I've,
right.
But what I write down,
just like what you were saying is a lot
of times very different than how you say
it in front of people because once you
start doing it in front of a live
audience,
he just started immediately trimming it
and moving things around on it.
You know?
I think it would be interesting if
somebody tried to create a comedy hour.
Yeah.
But without ever trying it in front of
an audience,
just like create the hour the best you
can just on the computer or whatever
going,
this is a good hour of comedy.
And then the first time you ever do it
is in front of an audience as the hour.
I just want to know how much of a
disaster that would be.
You know,
Carlin used to do that.
That's what Carlin used to do.
He used to write out his whole special,
like he used to write a new special
every year and he would write it and
then he would,
he had two,
two different ways of writing.
He would write it sober and they would
smoke pot and then punch it up and then
he would go and bring it to the stage.
And essentially it was like almost like
a one man show.
So you're saying he would create the
hour,
try it on stage,
but then I'm sure he would tweak it
before he was going to make an hbo
special or something like that.
Like I wouldn't do that wasn't the
finished product,
I think as T.
Right.
I see what you're saying.
Like I think as time went on,
the bits would get better.
He would tighten them up,
but he essentially never worked as
material out and he would abandon all of
it every year.
Uh,
he's amazing.
He was amazing.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a crazy way to do it.
Right.
You know,
I hear stories like that and I like,
you know,
I,
I like to think I'm adequate at what I
do.
And then you hear something like that
and you go,
if you put a bar graph of,
you know,
people talented.
And so yeah,
I'd be like a blip.
You know,
George Carlin up here.
Well,
he was an intensely creative guy.
Like he didn't have to do a whole new
hour every year and do a whole new HBO
special every year.
But that was his schedule.
And I think the rigidity of that,
like the discipline of that is one of
the things that kept him so creative and
so focused.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Well,
he was a genius.
I almost saw his last show,
Dan,
or one of his last shows,
he was performing in Las Vegas.
I was married at the time and my ex and
I were trying to figure out something to
do that evening.
I said George Carlin's in town,
and there was also a Neil diamond
impersonator.
So we saw,
we saw the neil diamond in person.
No.
So my story isn't,
I got to see one of George Carlin's last
sense as a human being.
I get to say I saw a wonderful meal time
impersonator.
Oh Christ Jesus Christ.
Is it good?
It was a good Neil diamond impersonator.
He was like,
yeah,
it was like that.
It was like really?
I was really happy to be there.
Vegas is one of the few places where you
can see a lot of impersonators there.
There was one hotel and I saw in Las
Vegas and I saw the signs for all the
shows and I realized everybody was a
fake something else.
There was like the rat pack and there
was like a Neil diamond impersonator and
then it was the guy that dresses like
all,
you know the women stars and stuff like
that.
I'm like,
none of the actual people are here.
These are all impersonators of other
famous people.
Yeah.
So,
so the people can be famous and then
people pretending to be,
those people can also become famous.
The weird.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
And they get really good at it.
And that was everybody in that casino
was a fake something else.
Have you ever seen that?
Uh,
Frank Marino guy that,
that's one of the guys I was talking
about.
Yeah.
I've never seen a show,
but I hear he's really good.
Yeah,
he's got like a whole show where he does
famous women.
Yes.
He's like,
uh,
are you allowed to call them drag queens
anymore?
I I'm,
I'm,
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say that.
I'm afraid to say any term about anybody
anymore.
Have you had,
have you ever had even off person is
offensive.
I don't even like to use the word person
cause I'm sure somebody out there going
who you calling a person black diamond
the best neil diamond tribute on the
planet.
It wasn't him.
No.
I would've remembered,
um,
or maybe he did.
Maybe black diamond was so good at it
that I didn't realize during the show
that he was black.
Don't you feel like that this,
I mean as far as like comedy,
having a bunch of landmines that you
could accidentally step on,
this seems like the most fraught with
peril time ever.
Absolutely.
What do you make of this?
I don't know.
I Dunno.
It's definitely,
um,
it's definitely an interesting time,
you know,
with everything been going on.
Um,
and,
and what's weird about comedy too is
that part of what makes it interesting
is pushing the envelope and be,
and people need to be willing to cross
the line to see what's over there.
I don't really do a lot of that kind of
comedy,
but I liked that there are people that
do that kind of comedy,
but that in conjunction with a
politically click correct world is a
very strange place.
Yeah.
It's a very strange place and people are
looking for someone to step over those
lines so they can attack them.
Yes,
yes.
There are forbidden subjects.
There's forbidden words.
There's forbidden takes on things.
I'm in.
This is going to sound like I'm
plugging,
I'm in this TV thing that Peter Fairly
is directing called loudermilk and it's
such a plugin.
That's the plug.
I'm glad I'm done with the plug.
It's about milk.
Loudermilk it's a valley brothers from
dumb and dumber.
Exactly.
Fucking geniuses.
Yes.
And I'm honored to be in the show and I
have a tiny little part in a thing and
uh,
it's about substance abuse.
Ron Livingston plays the main character
loudermilk and it's about substance
abuse,
but it's done in a very funny way.
So one of the first reviews that I read,
then I read a comment about it and
somebody wrote,
how dare somebody make fun of substance
abuse.
There's nothing funny about substance
abuse and it was just,
you know,
some person out in the Internet and,
and it just bothers me that people draw
these lines.
Like there's something funny about
everything,
everything that he said.
It depends on what you want to say about
it and what your point of view is.
You know,
every subject is fair game as far as I'm
concerned.
You know what I mean?
It depends on what your position is.
What's your point of view on it?
Yeah.
The idea that there's,
there's subjects that cannot be breached
is preposterous.
Crazy.
I agree,
but it just,
what is it?
I think it's that there's more people
that have the ability to complain about
things now than ever before because of
social media.
You can be in your underwear now.
The fact that you can be in your
underwear and feel like you're a
mouthpiece,
you're literally at home in your
underwear,
you know,
typing on on and I'm like this.
Yeah,
but you could write some great shit in
your underwear.
Like,
I don't care what you're wearing.
I just care.
No,
I'm talking about a critic.
Anybody anywhere saying,
oh,
right,
right.
You got to be a great critic and your
underwear and write a brilliant,
that's true.
Peace on something that's true.
I don't really care what they're
wearing,
but I see what you're saying.
But I'm just,
my point is,
anybody anywhere can have an opinion
about anything at any time.
And it's,
and in a way that's good,
but in a way you're going to get some
under qualified opinions.
You definitely gonna get that.
You're going to get a lot of opinions
from people that you would never choose
to talk to in real life.
You just,
you would weed them out,
but you can't weed them out online
because everyone's just text.
You know?
And,
and comedy is weird because everybody,
everybody has what their sense of humor
is.
And,
um,
so everybody thinks that the,
I've always been amazed that people
think that their sense of humor is the
correct one when people make these
absolute statements going,
he's funny.
She's not funny.
She is funny.
He's not funny.
[inaudible] who made you the comedy
barometer?
You know what I mean?
Whereas other art forms,
most people are wise enough to go.
Like if somebody that goes to a ballet
and doesn't like it,
you know,
at least you're wise enough to go.
I don't,
I don't appreciate the ballet.
You don't walk out going that Ballerina
socks.
There's gotta be some critical Ballerina
critics.
I,
I'm sure,
but,
but just because you don't like
something doesn't mean it wasn't good.
Right.
But it's not good to you.
I mean that's the case was fair Isaac.
But isn't that with everything,
right?
Music,
movies,
there's a lot of things that people love
that it's fair,
but if you,
if you qualify it that way,
if you say,
I don't find that person funny.
Okay.
Right.
But to put,
to make the blanket statement that he's
not funny.
He's not funny.
It's not up to you to say comedy is a
weird thing too,
in that it's one term that applies to a
bunch of different styles.
Whereas music,
you can go to see country western music,
you could see rap,
rock and roll.
There's all these different genres,
right?
Comedy is not like that.
It's just is it funny or is it not?
That's why it was always weird when
comedy clubs started exploding around
the country and there would be this
building that said comedy club on it and
Pittsburgh or de Moines and music.
Like you say,
a subdivided,
you don't just,
you know,
just go to a music club.
Hey,
there's the music club.
Do you want to go hear music?
Yeah.
Well everybody likes music,
but not everybody likes the same kind of
music.
Comedy is not subdivided.
Not,
not that I'm saying that it should be,
but,
but to just go into a room that says
comedy on it and think that you're
automatically going to be entertained is
kind of ludicrous.
Yeah.
But it's hard though if you don't know
who the comics are,
right?
It's like you don't know what their take
on things it's going to be.
And that's one of the things about a
nice local club.
Like say if you live in Nashville and
you go to Zania,
like,
oh,
I never heard of this guy,
but he's been on comedy central,
let's take a chance.
You literally have no idea what this
person's take is.
Right.
You know,
and it's great that you can go to a
place like that or you can go to the
Improv and Hollywood and you'll see like
10 different comedians one night or the
comedy store or where have you,
but you know,
you don't know what you're going to get.
Correct.
Which I think would be part of the fun.
Right.
For sure.
But you know,
for some people who like,
yeah,
you know,
want to draw a line and go,
well that person doesn't funny so
therefore I didn't have a good time.
What's like,
well you just took a chance,
one of the great parts about something
like the comedy store where you get a
new person every 15 minutes,
you know,
he's constantly new people.
You know,
when you writing over that,
Jamie,
you've written emails to Miami,
people would always hit me up during the
show.
Um,
what like when you see comedy today,
do you think that you would have,
oh,
you think about like when you first
started,
do you think you,
you would feel the same way about stand
up?
Have you had to start out today by
seeing how it's all fraught with peril.
Do you think you would have jumped in
any way?
I Dunno.
It feels different,
right?
It does.
And there's a,
um,
there were a lot fewer people doing it
when I started.
And to me it was just this internal
quest that came from within myself that
I want to do this.
Um,
and comedy evolves and now there is a
lot of autobiographical kind of comedy
and a lot of people really going into
their heart and soul and talking about
how they feel and stuff like that.
And,
and I love all comedy,
but my comedy kind of comes from a
different perspective.
It's more observational and you know,
I,
so I don't know if I were to watch all
of the comedy now,
if I would go,
I want to jump into that pool.
I'd like to think I would,
but I dunno,
you know?
Well,
I'd love your comedy and your comedy is
very observational and very silly,
but I always wonder,
like I wonder
today it seems like there's way more
uncensored comedy then there was when
you started on your me also,
you're one of the rare guys where are
fucking hilarious.
Like anybody can go see you.
Anybody.
Thank you.
Can you can bring children,
old people,
young people in the middle.
Anybody.
I mean,
you,
you're your comedy reaches,
you're probably,
in my opinion,
the most hilarious guy that reaches to
the widest audience.
I appreciate that.
It's an amazing thing that you've
figured out how to do.
Like you just figured out how to hit
this middle,
like this area where you could really
bring anybody to your show.
But everybody that I know really thinks
you're a very funny comedian.
Like it's,
it's,
it's very unusual.
Like a lot of times when a guy's like
squeaky clean,
like a,
he's,
it does not for me,
but everybody thinks you're funny.
So it's,
it's a weird thing.
I'm very honored by that.
Truly.
It means the world to me.
I mean,
I love,
I love making audiences laugh obviously,
but to have comedians like what I do for
you to say nice things like that,
other comedians,
you know,
it's,
it's a tremendous honor.
What is a,
is a real,
um,
there it's a feat.
And Gaffigan's done it too.
Like Africans,
another guy who's just goddamn hilarious
but squeaky clean.
Anybody can go see him,
you know?
And it's,
it's very admirable and a lot of ways,
it's not a lot of guys like you guys
anymore.
It's like,
it seems like people are either squeaky
clean or they're really dirty and they
don't necessarily appeal to people.
Like both.
I was like very dirty comedy.
I love of look extreme uncensored
comedy,
but I also love your comedy.
Thank you.
I feel the same way.
What's weird for me is if somebody comes
up to me after a show and say,
hey,
I liked your show.
So great,
thank you.
But then they want to like lean in and
go,
I'm glad you're not like,
like them,
you know,
it,
it's an us against them.
And I feel like saying I like them.
I like what they like,
what they do too.
And I like what I do.
It's the old,
remember when a stove top stuffing came
out,
stove top stuffing and the ad was,
wouldn't you rather have stuffing as
instead of potatoes and as a kid,
I used to think I want stuffing as well
as potatoes.
I don't want one over the other.
I want both of them.
So why can't both kinds of comedy exist
and be valid instead of,
I don't know.
I wish they'd stopped doing that.
Well there was a bunch of comics like
bill cosby.
Bill Cosby was always saying that the
comedians that did dirty comedy,
there's something wrong with them.
Like he was one of the big ones there
was pushing against it.
See I,
I don't feel that way,
I feel,
but I will say that I think there are at
least some comics who work blue who know
that pushing buttons,
we'll get a response.
I would hope that it's a truthful
organic message that you want to give as
the comedian and if happens to be dirty,
if it happens,
it happens to be Raunchy.
Great.
But if you're onstage going,
I know if I say fuck,
they'll laugh,
then it gets to button pushing.
Yeah.
And I find that to be a little like less
interesting to me.
Of course.
Yeah.
It's all about whether or not it's
really authentically that person's
interpretation of life,
you know?
And some people like whether it's Joey
Diaz or something like that,
it's just a very uncensored person.
Like talking to him offstage,
talking to him onstage.
Pretty similar.
Same Guy as far as how he views the
world and it just figured out a way to
turn that into an art form and then
they're,
you're right,
there's other people that are,
it's almost like,
it's almost like they could have been a
plumber,
but instead they decided to be a comics
like,
hmm,
how,
how do I make this work?
You know,
it's,
you know what I mean?
Nothing wrong with being a plumber,
but what I'm saying is that what they're
doing is manufactured and sort of just
artificial.
It's putting the audience first.
You know what?
What will they laugh at?
Oh,
I see that.
They'll laugh if you talk about this,
that and the other.
So therefore I will talk about this,
that and the other instead of it coming
from inside you.
You mentioned earlier about me figuring
out a way to read,
reach a wide audience,
which I appreciate the kind words,
but I never went that route.
I,
I just want to do what I think is good
and wherever it lands,
it lands and the fact that,
okay,
maybe a 10 year old kid can you get into
it and maybe a 78 year old woman can get
into it.
Great.
But that's not something,
I mean,
I don't lie.
I don't try to figure that out.
Right?
I didn't go,
well,
what can I do to get this wide range?
I just do what I do and whatever happens
happens,
and I'm just fortunate that,
that it ended that way.
Yeah,
no way.
You can tell that when you're on stage
too.
You know,
aren't you a,
you're getting ready to do another
special,
I just did a special Jesus that's going
to Air November,
November 21st it's called.
Oh Jesus.
What's an errand on Netflix?
Oh,
awesome man.
I have a,
I'm doing two specials for Netflix.
The first one comes out November 21st
and then I'll be doing another one in
2019 oh wow.
Are you planning that far ahead?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's Kinda of what I already have to
like move away from the material I've
already shot.
You know what I mean?
It's hard to doing it.
Hey,
that's me.
Why you got two mikes?
No,
those are nun chucks.
Oh,
the name of the specialist nun chucks
and flame throwers.
What a bizarre name.
First question is why?
It's a punchline from one of the jokes
and it's too long of a joke to try to
get into,
but a
record that at the paramount theater in
Denver called man,
that's awesome.
That's where a thompson garage just
recorded his special same theater.
Yeah,
it's a great,
great theater.
I'm pretty sure.
I love the crowds in Denver.
Denver's a shit.
I'm there Friday night.
Yeah,
I'm at the Belko.
Oh yeah.
Cool.
Love Denver.
Yeah,
so,
uh,
two shows,
by the way.
A second shows almost hold out.
Don't sleep
then.
A,
I'm doing phoenix on Saturday.
The COMERICA.
You ever done that place?
Yes.
It's big,
big and fun.
Yeah,
it should be good times.
Good Times.
I haven't seen you performing well.
I want to come see your show.
What are you doing tonight?
Where are you performing tonight?
Comedy store.
Maybe.
Come on down fucker.
Let's have a cocktail and adult beverage
as it works.
It's not October,
isn't it?
No,
it's not.
We can keep it in November.
I had a couple of shots last night.
Is November the 15th?
Are you building?
Are you there tomorrow night?
No.
Tomorrow I'm not.
I'm not because we were thinking of
maybe going over there to morning.
Oh,
maybe I will.
I will.
I will definitely consider it either
way.
We'll do it some other time and if not
tonight,
then soon.
Definitely.
Well,
thank you for coming,
man.
Joe.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
And November 21st Netflix.
Yes.
And uh,
I'm sure it's going to be awesome.
And then this weekend,
Santa Barbara?
No,
San Diego,
San Diego.
Friday,
Actin Stockton's Sunday,
and then in between the two long beach
on Saturday.
Beautiful.
Thanks brother.
Thank you.
Joe.
Brian,
Regan,
Ladies and gentlemen.
Woo.
[inaudible]
okay.